In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 26th, on which we commemorate,
our Holy Father Stephen, Bishop of Perm.
Born in the year 1340, St. Stephen was the son of a priest in Ustiug,
a city in the northern Dvina region, which had just come under the jurisdiction of Moscow.
He very early showed great capacities, and in the space of barely a year,
acquired a sufficient knowledge of the Scriptures to become a reader in the Cathedral,
where his father served.
An ardent thirst for holiness brought him while still very young
to enter the monastery of St. Gregory the Theologian in Rostov.
There he was able to learn Greek and perfect his knowledge of Holy Scripture.
Every time he heard of a wise man, he hurried to see him,
and spent long periods of time with him, to learn from his experience.
Once ordained priest, the desire grew in him to abandon his studies
and the security of the monastery, to go and to take the light of the gospel to the Xerians,
a pagan tribe in the land of Perm, on the western slopes of the Urals.
In order to prepare himself, he learned the Xerian language,
and after having created an alphabet, translated the Scriptures from the Greek.
He did not, however, as an obedient son of the Church, wish to undertake this mission on his own initiative,
and it was only after having received the blessing of Bishop Yarasimos of Kolomna,
who was then responsible for the Metropolitan Sea of Moscow,
that he left for the land of Perm, entrusting himself to Providence.
His sermons had, at first, only a very limited impact.
He succeeded in baptizing a small number of pagans who followed him on his travels
and questioned him with fervor about the faith.
He built a church for them, dedicated to the enunciation, the beginning of our salvation,
beside which he founded a monastery.
When the pagans went into the church, adorned with icons and resonating with divine hymnology,
they were stupified by such beauty and cried out,
great is the God of the Christians.
The majority of the people, however, remained hostile, and some of them even tried to kill the missionary.
But the hand of God protected him, and the saint was able patiently to continue his preaching.
One day, after having prayed in church that the Lord would bring the lost sheep into his fold,
he went to the pagan temple, driven by a divine impetus, and burned it down after having toppled all the idols.
He then waited peacefully beside the ruins.
When the pagans arrived, armed with cudgels, furious, and out to kill, he cried out,
Lord, into thy hands I commend my spirit, protect me under the wings of thy goodness.
The barbarians were suddenly stopped in their tracks, and their fury was changed to gentleness,
so completely that the saint was able to address them.
When will you finally renounce diabolical illusion, and escape the condemnation of eternal fire?
If these idols were really gods, they would have put the fire out and punished the perpetrator.
Abandon then these absurd superstitions, and acknowledge the one true God.
If you believe and receive holy baptism, you will be saved, and will receive the kingdom of heaven.
If you do not believe, you will be condemned to eternal torment.
Convinced by the saint, the idolaters in great numbers from day to day came to the faith, and were baptized.
The whole country was soon illumined with the grace of the gospel, and the saint, followed by a great number of neophytes,
went to every place where there were still idols, to destroy them by fire, together with the offerings made to them by the pagans.
Saint Stephen built two more churches in which he taught the people to read the book of hours, the Psalter, and other church books that he had translated into their dialect.
He also prepared the most suitable of his disciples for the deaconate and the priesthood, in order to give an indigenous clergy to this newborn church.
In spite of the saint's success, a sorcerer called Palm tried to return the people to paganism, using diabolically-inspired subterfuges.
Often being opposed to the saint in public discussions, Palm proposed to him that they should prove in action which was the true faith.
The saint accepted and suggested trial by fire and water.
After having prayed fervently to God, he merrily invited the sorcerer to enter the ready-prepared fire, together with him, hand in hand.
He walked into the flames, pulling the terrified sorcerer with him, the latter crying that he did not want to be burned alive.
Did you not suggest this yourself, to prove which is the living God, the saint asked him?
Why are you now bulking? The sorcerer acknowledged his fault, and also refused to throw himself into the ice of the river Vichegda.
Stephen said to him, will you now believe and be baptized, seeing that you have been overcome?
In spite of the cries of the crowd that was demanding death for Palm, the saint refused to harm him, calling Christ's teaching on gentleness and love
for one's enemy, and contented himself with having him driven from the country so that he could no longer corrupt the people of God.
The number of the faithful grew to such a point that the need was felt to elect a bishop to head this new church.
Saint Stephen then went to Moscow to inform the Grand Prince Demetri and Metropolitan Peaman of the wonders worked by divine grace in the land of Perm.
And to ask them to send a bishop for the harvest is great, but the laborers are few.
They decided that the saint himself was the most worthy of the episcopal ministry in that land that he had enlightened by his preaching and translations, and where he had founded the first churches.
He was consecrated in the year 1383, and on his return to Perm, where the people welcomed him with joy, went to work with tenfold energy, teaching, baptizing, founding churches, ordaining priests, and introducing with wisdom and discernment, the structure and discipline of the church.
He also established monasteries and became the provider of the poor, and consolar of the afflicted.
As an attentive pastor, he did not devote all his concern only to the soul, but also nourished the body. During a famine in Perm, he brought wheat from Vologda and organized its free distribution to the people.
Sometime before his blessed death, Saint Stephen undertook a further journey to Moscow to visit Metropolitan Cyprian.
He first brought his flock together and basing himself on the holy scriptures exhorted them to remain firm in the Orthodox faith, and to be united in charity that was without hypocrisy.
Then, after having told them that his end was near, he entrusted them to the Lord, and left for Moscow.
Hardly had he arrived when he felt himself to have become weaker, and a few days later, on the 26th of April in the year 1396, he gave his soul into God's hands to go and join the choir of the Holy Hierarchs.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.